what up cheese bags I'm Kevin I'm Carly
hey I'm Katya hey I'm Nick hi I'm
Stephanie hi I'm Kyra and today we're
drying something mysterious today you'll
be drawing each other as animal crossing
villagers oh okay okay
I've never played animal crossing dude I
like 300 hours in my game
what's the animal crossing I'm just
kidding okay Carly I have no idea what
to do
are there any people in the game oh yeah
I know you play as like a little
villager okay and then you have just a
bunch of little animal villagers that
like move into your town and you just
decorate your house and make everything
look nice it's almost like everything's
kind of I guess like chibi fired yes
know how you'd say no I know I do know
that I because of what I've seen I do
know that everything is like big head
small body like very cutesy right mm-hmm
okay I'm gonna start there
so have you been playing Animal Crossing
lately so I don't have the new one but
uh I was obsessed with the original on
GameCube mm-hmm so I love Animal
Crossing do you have a favorite
character or like a villager right now
I've got Bob on my Island right now is
it Bob really popular I think so he's
pretty cool
he's pretty chill how about you um I
think my favorite character right now is
tonight he's the he's a pink I love
bunny so I have all pink and all rabbit
villagers right now um as much as I can
and so snake is pink and he's got this
ninja outfit on I'm gonna draw you as an
animal Oh as an animal
oh okay putting a creative twist on this
so yes the question is which animal
do you identify the most with if you had
to choose between like a cat or an
alligator for me what would you what
would you choose I'm gonna you know what
I'm gonna go alligator
I'm gonna go alligator but why not it
why not if I'm gonna fail I'm gonna fail
big it's been like such a great game to
play right now just to like chill and
just like play some animal crossing have
you like gone to anybody's birthdays or
weddings in there animal crossing no I
didn't you know people were doing that
Wow I should do that for my birthday
what I don't understand is how is it a
game it's nice escapism it's very kind
of meditative oh I don't want to say
therapeutic but it honestly is it's such
a comforting thing to play yeah no I'm
just used to games that I have like
objectives what do you win you win the
satisfaction of a job well done no
people like my husband's actually like
this he doesn't really like to do the
chores part of the game I already have
chores and cleaning it is like you're
totally doing chores like there's just
something about it that just kind of
yeah you can turn your brain off and
just get lost in the world yeah there's
not really any major conflict and pick
up some wood and why would I want to do
that in a game something that you can
pick up play for a few minutes or a
couple hours that kind of like
non-committal miss it gives you a sense
of like you soul or a sense of like
comfort just that idea of getting to go
and just be like you're gonna make
whatever you want cuz you want your
house to look killer listen I want my
actual house to look killer so why
wouldn't I go to work on that cuz a cute
little animal told you to and you don't
want to hurt their feelings now that is
a compelling argument so Kyra has has a
draw and coming along how you doing good
I feel very like at home drawing
something like this like into my
favorite things to draw are like cute
tiny any animal
people what would you like your villager
to be wearing like what what's your
normal wardrobe ah man
normal wardrobe is not exciting but I
feel like if I had to make a request I'd
say make me look expensive oh okay
so to kind of turn you into a villager I
think what I'm trying to focus on is I
think bringing your personality and
because it's it's hard to translate like
you said human features to an animal
creature but I think if you can bring in
the things about the person that
resonates to you into that into that
design then that that will be very
effective and your hair and I think I
can bring in aspects of your hair into
this design that will be pretty iconic
is that yes very lovely feature of your
many lovely features thank you
next how you holding up over there oh
good good good got a nice good like
rough drawing now so I'm going to start
to kind of doing some color maybe inking
it how about you
ah doing pretty good I've moved on to
color and my method is usually sketches
first and then I block out big blocks of
color and then shadows and forms and
whatnot and then I do my line work
blocked I'm still not sure exactly what
the color scheme is gonna be I think
I'll definitely bring in the reddish
reddish-brown for the hair and that
black and white shirt didn't he's sure
about the rest
experiment listen Carly you're gonna
have to temper your expectations when
you see this drawing because a I've
never played the game before and B
apparently I don't know what alligator
suck
honestly Sam I feel like I kind of
copped out with a cat on this one I was
like you want a cookie cat I know what I
was doing Nick have you ever played
Donkey Kong are you kidding me
have I ever played Donkey Kong it's like
one of the first things I ever played
wasn't really the original Donkey Kong
that's right here cuz I'm not looking at
you at the moment but would you say your
hair is like hmm like more of like a
like a like a blondish gray kind of
situation or is it more of like you know
some people have like kind of slightly
gray hair but it's like almost like a
weird lavender I would say it's more of
a blonde gray but our audience would say
that I'm fully gray oh my gosh
they come all set meet you I'm good to
go Steph how do you think you did I
think I did pretty good I wish I'd had a
better plan for the coloring not gonna
lie but I think that the actual look is
very cute oh good I would I would love
to have this this character moved to my
village I'm so excited
do you think it looks like a like a
villager that would be in the game I
think so I think maybe the mouth is a
little too smug okay somehow I feel like
we can't make it smug enough Wow let's
undo each other okay sounds good
oh I wish I could bring bow hair do you
see why I was asking you about Donkey
Kong look like a monkey Nick I formally
invite you to celebrate your birthday on
my island since I can't see you in your
life
hey that says a great idea we should do
that I will see you on your island okay
wait who's actually this is really a
hundred is it perfect
oh my god wait know I actually like love
this I gave you like ninety bells as you
I mean I made you a belly anair oh you
know it you know it I'm sorry that I
left you broken in the grass
oh my god that's so cute I love how did
you get those lines so clean oh thank
you I love that you made me a sheep I
love she yeah I I just knew it I knew
the minute it was like draw each other
and that style I was like she I'm really
glad that during like this time we're
all locked down and separated from each
other that we can use like this and
drawing each other as like a fun way to
connect yeah absolutely I honestly think
that animal crossing could not have come
at a better time
oh yeah it's really been I think
extremely helpful for a lot of people
and that's that's important
hey thanks for watching be sure to join
us on Instagram and Twitter for
challenges giveaways and the chance to
have your drawings featured on an
upcoming show
[Music]